so I get a lot of questions in the
mailbag that are good questions but the
answers are really going to be
full-length even for a Minnesota be even
a two-minute answer
so today's just gonna be a collection of
those and so we're gonna start it off
with do you think that something like
story expanding DLC should or could
impact one's interpretation of the
original product yes and no yes and no a
little perspective before I dig deeper
DLC is a bit of a unique thing that
allows for modular expansion of a
storyline in a size and delivery that
was previously really really uncommon
even across like all different media
like movies comics television like and
even still in video games relative to
the total volume and composition of DLC
that is released Story DLC is less
common and often steers towards
unimportant plot cul-de-sacs maybe
adding some mild characterization but
it's still rare for DLC to really ask
the player to reevaluate their view of a
core character burrial see and some of
the chewer your mass effected DLC are
still there the exception rather than
the norm also DLC tends to have a
relatively low adoption rate relative to
the main game or say a full-on expansion
pack or a sequel and as such tends to
have much less traction in the
collective culture so with that in mind
there are I think two layers to the
question should you let DLC impact the
way that you view and interpret or work
as a whole yes absolutely
if DLC or a tie-in novel or an online
short or a supplementary comic book or
any other expansion of a story impacts
the way that you feel about it let it
and at the same time you should still
keep that raw original experience you
know filed away somewhere in your brain
because that's the version that more
people are likely to hold for themselves
and so you want to keep that
understanding present when you're
talking about a story so that you can
communicate effectively with others
think about them in the same way that
you think about different adaptations of
Shakespeare or whether or not hands shot
first and next up do I ever
intentionally back away from letting my
technical knowledge seep into folding
ideas so I actually studied
communications before I went into the
technical side so I've always had a
broad interest in storytelling both as a
subject of study and as a creator and
rather than backing away from the
technical I feel like I've tried to
inject it wherever appropriate and I am
in many ways an apologist for accidental
meaning or things that end up in a story
because of the logistical limitations of
production and next up so why does the
angry game smasher smashing Zanger Lee
well he is quite angry and enjoy
smashing games on YouTube
and next up has there been a worse movie
than Jurassic world in the last year in
the few years even um
paul blart mall cop 2 small bart paul
cop 2 to cop blair mall paul blart mall
to mall cop Whitewater Paul Pall Mall
mall mall mall mall cop Blart paul to
mall cop flight Blart Paul Paul Mall
mall mall mall blart mall cop 2 to
mobile art small park Walmart mall blart
mall cop
blarp blarp paul blart mall cop to mall
bar pull cop 2 to cop to cop blart mall
to cop blart mall paul Blart paul to
mall cop blarp blarp Paul Pall Mall mall
mall mall blart mall cop mall Bart Paul
cop and next up what do you usually put
on your french fries personally ketchup
or Mayo or a mayo ketchup mix or gravy
and cheese curd which you may know as
poutine or cheese curd and butter
chicken which is butter chicken poutine
or I just shove them in my face bear
with all the dignity of someone buying
two large fries at 3:00 a.m. and the
24-hour drive-through and next up I hate
the phrase guilty pleasures because even
though I might like a thing while
acknowledging that it's bad feeling
guilty for liking it seems ridiculous
Jurassic world is the closest I've come
is there a better more accurate way we
can talk about enjoying things we
readily admit our bad so I've fallen in
love with the phrase great trash or even
if it's just trash and not that great
just own it if it speaks to you it
speaks to you you don't need to
apologize for liking what you like even
if it's Jurassic world you're wrong but
you don't need to apologize
you should apologize but you don't need
to apologize
you are wrong though
and you should apologize but you don't
need to and next up
do you have any opinion on what happened
to make em night shell Mons more recent
films
stop being critically and commercially
successful this one's actually really
simple
first they stopped being good and then
they stopped being fun so thank you
those were some great questions some fun
questions keep them coming and in the
meantime to coppler mall paul Blart ball
to mall cop white water Paul Paul Mall
mall mall mall Bart Hall cop
Blart Paul to mall cop blarp blarp Paul
Pall Mall mall mall mall blart mall cop
to to mobile art small Park Walmart mall
blur amen